a charter school resource officer is
under investigation in Florida today
after arresting two children ages 6 and
8 Orlando Police say Reserve Officer
Dennis Turner was not authorized to make
those arrests last week national
correspondent Jericka Duncan shows us
how a six year old ended up in handcuffs
when six year old Cairo was arrested
Thursday at Lucius and Eman it's an
academy in Orlando
her grandmother Marilyn Kirkland
couldn't believe the call say there was
an incident and she kicked somebody and
she's being charged Kirkland says even
after she explained that kaya's outburst
was likely the result of a medical
condition the six-year-old was still
charged with battery I said you know she
has a sleep disorder sleep up you know
he says well I have sleep apnea I don't
behave like that Orlando Police say a
department policy that requires approval
to arrest anyone younger than 12 was not
followed in either kaya rolls case or
one involving an unidentified
eight-year-old Dennis Turner was the
arresting officer and according to the
Orlando Sentinel he was given a written
reprimand in 2015 for excessive use of
force involving a Taser
as for Kirkland she says her
granddaughter was even taken to a
juvenile center for fingerprints and a
mug shot no six year old child should be
able to tell somebody that they had
handcuffs on them and they were riding
in the back of a police car Turner has
been suspended pending the outcome of
that internal investigation by Orlando
PD he did not respond to our request for
comment
in a statement police chief Orlando real
own said as a grand parent of three
children less than 11 years old this is
a very concerning issue to me I was like
somebody needs training yeah retraining
that one handcuffs fingerprint our six
year old kid come on Jericka thank you
very much